and multiple people tell me the movie uh
king of staten island i think it's
called
is that the one it's about uh y and p
davidson pete's david pete davidson's
dad died on 9 11
and so it's it's about like what his
life kind of it's sort of he's not a
comedian in the movie but it's about his
his life and his family you know some
things are changed but
did you guys watch it yeah i watched it
separately from him but it's
it's really good it's excellent is that
what the
and bill byrne who's a good friend of
mine and a comedian and he's amazing and
super talented and is incredible in it
yeah i went on bilber's podcast and he
was screaming about the federal reserve
for like half the time
to the point where i thought he was
going to run for president he's always
equally equally furious about like it
could be
he's super educated though that's that's
the scariest part is a comedian who's
educated and mad
like i was i was very impressed with how
much he knew but he was very mad
and i was i was there for it i loved it
uh but is that
is that what the fdny culture is like in
that movie
yeah i mean a lot of it is very accurate
i mean this is also like
a while ago but you know it's definitely
it's definitely very active i mean
there's a there's a subculture to the
fire department and they understand each
other in a way nobody else does it's a
lot like comics in a way
except you know again they save people's
lives and we're
narcissists but uh they i mean there's
they work off adrenaline you know their
highs are really high
and then the downtime is like awesome
you know so
and the lows are very low and very scary
so it's like
there's this and there's this language
they speak that nobody else speaks like
when we hang out at the table at the
comedy cellar this
this club that we it's kind of my home
club when i'm in new york and i
miss being there so much now we just sit
at that table and like slam wings and
our dumb faces and just say unspeakable
things to each other you know
and then a comedian will come up with
his girlfriend or or
or a female comic will come up with her
boyfriend or whatever and like the
comics get annoyed they're like
so-and-so had to bring up and we'll call
them a civilian we'll be like oh they
had to bring us a billion you know
because we can't speak the way we speak
because we're just we're it's disgusting
we're animals and we just say like crazy
nonsense that other people are called by
environment are the same
are people gonna get offended just we
don't feel like we could talk as
comfortably
you know with non-comics i think that's
how a lot of comedians feel and like
also people that aren't comedians
they'll sort of come and
try to be on in a certain way or be like
you should i should be a comedian you
should put that in your skit you should
put this in your scalp we're crazy
you've got to come to my job you get
that a lot like you should come to where
i work and i'm like
i don't really need to go to like
the store you work at in tampa like i
have a good idea of what happens there
i'll get material i think on my own but
people do that and so comics get like
weird they don't want
yeah they just want to be comedians and
not think about it yeah i think it's
kevin hart's got a piece where he's like
people come up to him and they're like
hey man be funny and he's like what the
[ __ ]
like and like yeah come on let's go like
tell me a joke and he's just like
this isn't how this works like and he
has this whole thing about just like
people expect comedians to be funny 100
of the time no matter where they are
at all like literally just walk up to
you while you're eating dinner and be
like rachel come on tell me a joke like
that's your job yeah they don't
understand you have like other aspects
to your
i mean a lot there are a lot of people
that do and they're really lovely but a
lot of times people from the audience
right after the show will sort of expect
you to be
funny or they'll come up and kind of nag
you like give you [ __ ] and think like
that's how you like to be talked to
or something so it's weird and
environment is the same kind of thing
when i stopped by the firehouse like i
feel like the
chemical change in the room when i walk
into that firehouse kitchen because
and i want to be like no i'm an animal
too like you can keep saying the
disgusting things you were just saying
she hear my friends we're like 10 times
worse but there's some weird
similarities
you know have you walked into the
firehouse yet and just roasted a bunch
of them
like i feel like that immediately puts
you on even playing field just walk in
one day
and just the worst things that you would
say to your comedian friends
just go down the line every single
fireman and my guess is that not only
will they not be mad
they'll just come right back and then
your husband will have to go hey guys
come on i mean i can't i wouldn't do
that because they don't know me like
that but i'll
so i wouldn't i don't know them to [ __ ]
with them like that you know what i mean
but
i will he's what's called a bouncing
captain so he goes to different
firehouses so he might be at one
firehouse this week another firehouse
next week and he's the boss
so the guys are like you know nervous
around so it's fun to drop in because
they don't know that i'm his wife at the
beginning
so there's one firehouse where they all
stand outside and they
like the younger guys there's like a
little bit of a separation you know
between the boss like he wouldn't go out
with them or whatever so
he'll be up in his office uh smoking a
cigar or
watching newborn or something and um
i'll walk up outside
and then like so the young guys they
stand outside
with dog treats so that if a cute girl
comes by with a dog they can give it to
her you know so
it was like halloween and i walked up
kind of slowly
and um one of the guys did that thing
where he looks back at the other guy and
tells him there's an ass worth reviewing
as you're passing they go like
you know and they think we don't know
this like this is the most simple
obvious eye contact and i was spirit
cluttered that i hadn't asked what
they're doing but
they could do this he looks back to his
friends and then so they all look and so
then i just kind of slowed down
and it was like you know halloween so
there's a lot of drugs in the street so
i was like
it's really scary out there boys first
of all thank you for your service
i think i could come in for a little bit
and take cover just a lot of douchebags
out there and i'm frightened you know
and they just did not expect that so one
of the guys was like yeah sure come on
in uh we get some snacks in the kitchen
uh yeah absolutely come in you know so i
walk in i'm like
is captain brandon here by any chance
and they just like turn [ __ ] white
you know
and then he calls him on the little
rocky like
he goes boss your boss is here and so
pete comes down he wouldn't give a [ __ ]
first of all he's not jealous he'll just
hand me to anybody that asks for me
just be like have her back within a week
or so but uh
and another time i went by the firehouse
and this was fun
so sometimes i'll bring buy food like
you know wings from the comedy cellar or
whatever
and a lot of them are really uh
attractive
um so i'll look for any excuse to just
like pop in
i beat something you know so i come by
and i have a box
they get very suspicious of outside food
right because people bring probably like
weird
jacked up gangrenous things like just
some old lady that brings them some
strange
[ __ ] and they may get a chip a chip may
get implanted in their brains if they
eat the cookies
exactly all right so you so you bring up
the box so they're a suspicious group in
general so i come by
with this box and these cookies i bought
um
and they had a like a tie around them
and i go to one of the guys don't worry
i bought these
you know they're not i didn't bring them
from my home and then uh they don't know
i'm you know pete's wife and i go
and they're all tied up you can see i
just got them from the place and the guy
was like you like to be tied up
so then so one of the other guys
happens to know because he used to work
at a different firehouse but i'm pete's
wife he's like hey come here buddy he's
like what do you like to be dead he
thinks of just some neighborhood
[ __ ] that you know has the hots for
firemen to come by with cookies
one of the guys is like hey let me talk
to you for a second buddy it kind of
takes him on a walk around the rig and
the guy
came back just shook you know it was so
fun to [ __ ] with them
and i told pete on the way home and he's
like oh he'll have a nickname forever
for that incident you know but he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
again he'll just hand me right off it's
literally like the army
like you just the the culture is so
different
and i feel like you get the best of both
worlds
which is like you get to participate in
the communi uh comedians world
and then you get to go and you know
exactly the buttons to push in the
firemen world and they have no like
it's unfair of you to walk in there to
these unsuspecting suspects
and just destroy them and then you're
like
and then you have like the trump card
you're like oh yeah by the way can i see
the boss
yeah i know it's so it's the best i love
it um
i love it yeah also it's fun just to
like
i mean it's fun to just tell everybody
like i tell
come on i tell anyone he's a firefighter
i'm like i'll be at cvs
and i'll be like they could take their
badge out they call it tinum
i'd be like turtle you know like he'll
be like we're in a cvs they just don't
have the kind of gum i'm looking for
it's not a tinum situation but i just
have fun with it you know
until um a global pandemic hits
exactly yeah it's it's it's cool though
it's a cool world
and uh they're fun they're definitely a
fun group firefighters